翻訳: Maki Sugimoto
校正: Machiko Takahashi
日常の食事は
私たちの体が健やかに生きるために
必要な栄養素を体に届けるという
役割をしています
自分が特別に好きなわけじゃ
なかったはずなのに
口にした時に
「ああこれ食べたかった」って
カラダの中からエネルギーが
溢れてきたという経験はありませんか？
私は気がつきました
日常の食事
毎日これだけ何回も訪れて
食べて経験しているのに
言葉がない ということにです
「インスタ映え」という言葉があって
派手な食事 綺麗な食事は写真に撮って
「これが美味しかった」「 楽しかった」って
話されるんですけれども
一方で日常の普段の食事
特にネガティブな感情や経験
こういうことは話されることがないんですね
それゆえに その食事の健康や
食事に対する不満とか不安を
話す機会も関係もないという
そこに大きな課題があるということに
気がつきました
私がこの活動をする
きっかけになったのが
「社員食堂」という言葉です
私 2007年から７年間
７千人のいろんな国籍の社員が集まる—
社員食堂のディレクターをしていました
この福岡に 支社の社員食堂を
作りに来たこともあります
それを始めた頃に
「ここをレストランにしたい」という
声を聞いたんです
その時に「えっ レストランじゃない」って
心の中から強く否定の気持ちが
湧き上がってきたんですけど
「じゃあ 何なの？」という答えが
出ないままでいました
そしてその会社を辞めて
2016年の春に ご縁があって
日本橋 大伝馬町にある
社員食堂ラボという所の
ディレクターをすることになりました
この社員食堂ラボ
普通 社員食堂といったら
会社の中にあって
そこで働いている社員の人たちが
集まってくる場所だって思いますよね
でもここはちょっと違うんです
クリエイターの人たちが集まってきて
そしてそこは シェアキッチンなんですね
「あれ 社員食堂って何だろう？」
もう１回 考える機会が訪れたんですね
それで考えて考えて
やっと出てきた答えが
社員を「働く人」
食堂を「日常の食」
それを「ラボ」する場所
それが「社員食堂ラボ」なんだと
思った時に
今まで長く持っていた謎の塊が
スーッと溶けていく
そんな実感を得ました
そして働く人たちの
日常の食事の課題が
いっぱいあるって事にも
その時に気がついたんです
食事って昔は お腹いっぱい食べて
とにかくカロリーを手に入れること
それが目的でした
でも今の現代の都市の課題は違います
食べる目的は 私２つあると思っています
１つはまず「心が生きるため」
美味しくて嬉しい お腹いっぱいで幸せ
といったことですね
ここは レストランが担当する
領域だと思っています
そして２つ目が「体が生きること」
私たち生き物ですから 生き物として
体が健やかに生きるために
必要な栄養素を
ちゃんとバランスよく摂れること
これが「体が生きるため」です
これを食堂が担当するんだっていうふうに
思ったんです
そしてなぜ働く人なのかというと
働いている人 特に外食で
食事を賄おうとしている人は
なかなか食事が大変
都市は美味しいもので溢れています
だけど だいたい炭水化物
タンパク質 そして揚げ物
そういうものは いっぱい
あるんですけれども
一方でそれとバランスをとって
必要なビタミン 無機質
それに必要なのが野菜
たっぷりの野菜
それに 芋 豆 果物といったもの
なんですけれども
それがなかなか取れない
本当にここが大変です
食堂や外食のレストランというのは
「このバランスは自分で取ってね」
という前提で
だいたい構成されています
で この「自分で取ってね」
昔はお母さんや奥さんが
家の中で一生懸命考えて
用意してくださってたんですけれども
今はなかなか そういう人がいないんです
なぜなら単身者が多い
そして女の人も働いている
なかなかご飯が作れない
そして賃貸のマンションは
どんどんキッチンが小さくなっていって
なかなかちゃんとご飯を作る所に
なっていないんですね
そして働いていると毎日忙しい
「今日はお昼ごはんはカップ麺と
おにぎりで済ませちゃった」とか
「夜 食べ損なってスナック菓子食べて
寝ちゃった」みたいなことがあって
それがたまたま ならいいんですけれども
もう毎日続いている
そうすると「ああこれで大丈夫かなー
こんなんじゃ 病気になんないかな」って
不安や不満があるんですね
だけど なかなか
それが話す機会がないから
その問題が解決されないんです
だから働く人の日常の食には
いろんな解決されないテーマが
あると気がついたんです
そこで社員食堂ラボで始まったのが
「おとな食堂」という活動です
この「おとな食堂」は
「話す」「 作る」「 食べる」の
３つの３部構成からなっています
さて皆さん 今日 会場の外に
ホワイトボードでちょっと
お聞きしているんですけれども
「話す」「 作る」「 食べる」の３つのうち
自分が一番大事だなと
思うのはどれですか
ひとつ選んで今 私
訊きますので教えてください
いいですか じゃあまず
「話す」の人
少し手が挙がりましたね
ありがとうございます
はい じゃあ「作る」の人
挙がってきましたね
ありがとうございます
「食べる」の人
いっぱい挙がりましたね
はい ありがとうございます
やっぱりみんな食べるの好きですね
おいしいですもんね
いま伺った質問は
ひとつの答えではありません
いま聞かれて 自分がどれかなって思って
選んだひとつ それが正解です
そこを大事にしてください
おとな食堂の「話す」は
日常の食事の中でも
どちらかというと
「言ったら恥ずかしいな」とか
「ちょっと嫌だな」みたいな
ネガティブなことを話してもらうことを
大事にしています
ソーシャルメディアだと
キラキラした話で
溢れているんですけれども
話してもらうのは
「ご飯作りたくない」とか
「もう野菜嫌い」とか
あとは「ポテチいっぱい食べちゃう」
みたいな話をしてもらいます
それをちょっと恥ずかしい
でも言ってみる
自分の声と言葉で
そうすると 自分の耳が聞くんです
「あれあれ？」
「キライって言ったけど
何が嫌いなんだっけ」とか
「あれ それ食べたかったんだっけ」
「食べて満足したかな」っていうふうに
頭が働き出すんです
ここで大事なのは
正解を得ることではないんです
自分の中から出てきた言葉を
取り出して そして
そこで確かめること
ただそれだけです
それが「話す」
おとな食堂の「作る」は
お料理をするというプロセスよりも
まずは素材 素材にのっている
生産者さんと生産地
そして食べる人の
体調のことを繋いでいく
そこを考えるということを
大事にしています
おとな食堂では参加者に
「食べたい野菜を持ってきてください」
というふうにお願いしています
そうすると いろんな素材の
ストーリーが集まってくるんです
「近所の八百屋さんの
地元の名前がついたトマトです」とか
「地産者さんの中の畑で爆発しそうだった
キャベツを送ってもらいました」とか
「お母さんが実家で作ってくれた
育ちすぎたゴーヤです」
そんな感じで いろんなストーリーが
集まってきます
さらに「今日はちょっと苦いものが
食べたかったんですよ」って言ったり
「いい香りが欲しかったんです」って言って
自分の体調と相談した素材選びの話を
してくださる方もいます
そんなふうに素材を通して
いろんな人々や風景が
繋がっているということを
知ってもらいたいんですね
お料理を作るプロセスの中というのは
自分の人間としての五感を
一番フル稼働させる時間です
今日は大根を持ってきました
これは糸島の大根なんですけれども
大根の葉っぱ ざっくり切って
トントントントンって包丁で切る時の
そのリズムの良さと感触
カブをパッと切ってって
塩もみにする
そうすると天井の光が反射して
キラキラって輝くんですね
あとは 料理をすると炒めたり
茹でたりした時に出てくる湯気
それの香りと温度
胸の奥まで すーって
吸いたくなります
そんなプロセス
あとは食べる人の
口の中に入った時のことを想像してみる
今日はガリって食べたいなぁ
と思ったら 大きく切って
もし小さいお子さんがいたら
じゃあちょっと食べやすいように
というふうに小さく切ったり
この中にいろんな気遣いがあるんです
そういうことのひとつひとつ
食事を形作っているエネルギーを
食べる人に渡していただきたいんです
私はこれからの日常の食は
みんなが作らなくてもいいと思っています
そして毎日 作らなくてもいい
でもその代わり こういうふうに
食事に込められたメッセージを
渡す 受け取る ということが
とても大切になってくると思っています
食べる人に話して
そのエネルギーを伝えてほしいのです
いい時ばかりではありませんが
「作る」の中で知ったこと
発見や経験や工夫
それを話して伝えることで
いろんな人や場所と繋がり
体が支えられているということを
食べる人が知るきっかけを
作って頂きたいのです
次に おとな食堂の「食べる」は
たっぷりの野菜料理を好きなだけ
「心ゆくまで食べてもいいよ」という
アクティビティです
先日食べてもらったらひとりで
１キロ食べちゃった人がいました
火が通ってない生野菜のサラダではない
火が通った野菜を
お腹いっぱい食べてもいいという
シチュエーションは
意外とないんです
そこでみんな そのたくさんの
野菜料理を目の前にすると
体から「わぁ食べたい」という
エネルギーが溢れ出てくるのを
いつも私は感じます
食べてみて 心地が良いかどうか
体調が変わるかどうか
皆さんも食事の中で
ご自身の体が喜ぶ実感
それを観察してみてください
こんな風に日常の食を軸にして考えると
「自分の体は何が欲しいのかなあ」
ということと
この自分の身体が生きることを
支えてくれている人々のエネルギーに
気がつく きっかけになります
ご自身の体が 呼吸が深く入って
体に力が入る それが答えです
「あ もしかしたら あの時のことかな」って
思い出せる経験はありませんか？
ぜひ身近な方と
日常の食事の思いや発見を
交わす時間を持ってみてください
そこからが皆さんそれぞれの
「おとな食堂」の始まりです
（拍手）